good morning and welcome to sky news
breakfast live from wembley and what
could be a historic day for english
football lionesses have a date with
destiny this afternoon as they take on
eight-time winners germany in the euro
2022 final i'll be hoping to lift the
trophy for the first time and win the
first major tournament title for any
england team since
1966. england aren't the underdogs but
they'll have the support of a sellout
crowd here at wembley and what's
expected to be the biggest home tv
audience on record for a women's
football match
well let's just remind you of the
lionesses road to the final the squad
face little resistance in the group
stages it was perfect winning one nil
against austria a whopping eight nil
against norway and five nil against
northern ireland
the next challenge came in their
quarter-final match against spain where
they came from behind late on to win 2-1
in extra time
well that put them through to a
semi-final match against the bookies
favorites the world number two sweden
who they beat 4 nil and that of course
set up today's head-to-head with germany
adele robinson reports now on the final
showdown at wembley
it's the start of a journey not the end
their last training session before the
lionesses attempt to overturn history
it's a fairytale fixture with the
history behind it but i think for us
you would never expect to get to a final
without playing the best team in the
tournament and i you know in terms of i
think
the journey that both of us have been on
you've got the two
two teams that have had the best
tournaments in the final which is the
best thing
germany say they want to take wembley
with their ninth title and a record
unbeaten run in a euro final their press
conference calm and confident
we're just glad to be allowed to be here
to have this privilege we've dreamed of
to play a final against england at
wembley i don't know if there will be or
have been many bigger moments in sport
for our players
well when you reach final
um then you're one of the best teams in
the tournament i think we have a very
good team too and we don't fear anyone
meanwhile a re-versioned football anthem
[Music]
tailored to the women's journey
[Music]
a sign in itself for watershed moments
already passed
what have we got that they haven't do
you think
the home crowd the home crowd i think
i think if you speak to the germans what
they would want is to have a crowd like
we've got
sizing up an empty stadium soon to be
full and a quiet moment to absorb
the magnitude of a dream within reach
adele robinson sky news
well attendance records have been
shattered at euro 2022 let's have a
quick look at those already almost 488
000 people have attended the tournament
before today's final
well that's more than double the
previous record for a women's european
championship
and that was set five years ago when
just over 240 000 fans attended euro
2016 in the netherlands
and with the finals sold out the overall
attendance for this year's tournament is
expected to top 570
000
and what's more fans have the chance to
be part of a new all-time attendance
record for euro final tournament match
in both the men's and the women's game
with wembley's capacity being 87 000.
the current record was set at the men's
final in 1964 between spain and the
soviet union which was played in front
of around 79 000 spectators
it is going to be the romantic final
today and let's hope there is uh
football on the pitch to match all the
expectation vanessa back to you
jackie thank you well now the news has
emerged the prince of wales as
charitable fund accepted a donation
reported to be a million pounds from the
family members of salmon bin laden back
in 2013.
news of the seven figure donation was
first reported in the sunday times
but clarence house has denied that
prince charles was personally involved
well joining me now is our correspondent
studio children's studio clarence
howells denying that prince charles was
not personally i was personally involved
but ultimately questions and eyebrows
will be raised about judgment and
whether his charity should be associated
with bin laden's family members yes i
think the first thing we should say that
this has nothing to do with osama bin
laden but the bin laden families of
course a very well-known family in saudi
arabia well known for being a big
businessman and so these payments were
made by um
shafiq bin laden and bacco bin laden who
are two half-brothers of osama bin laden
this is all from the sunday times
reporting which says that uh the prince
of wales had a private meeting
with um
bacca bin laden at clarence house in
october 2013. now that's two years after
osama bin laden was killed by u.s
special forces during a raid in pakistan
the paper says that the prince agreed to
the donations despite objections from
his advisors
and the foundation into which the money
was deposited and that after the payment
was made that his several of his
advisers had meetings with him in person
to plead with him to return the money
saying it wasn't a good look well as you
say we've had two responses one from
clarence house and once one from the
foundation both denying that the prince
had any decision-making role in this
i'll read these out to you this one
first from the prince of wales
charitable fund which says the donation
from
bakker bin laden in 2013 was carefully
considered by pwcf trustees at the time
due diligence was conducted with
information sought from a wide range of
sources including government the
decision to accept the donation was
taken wholly by the trustees any attempt
to sort otherwise to suggest otherwise
is misleading and inaccurate and a very
similar response from clarence house
which says the prince of wales
charitable fund has assured us that
thorough due diligence was undertaken in
accepting this donation
the decision to accept was taken by the
charities trustees alone and any attempt
to characterize it otherwise is false
well all of this comes after reports
last month that the prince of wales had
accepted large sums of money in cash
payments often in fortnum and mason
carrier bags from the former prime
minister of qatar sheikh hamad bin jazim
bin jabra athani now at the time
clarence house said that that money was
taken appropriately and that it was
deposited into the bank properly it also
follows an investigation launched by the
metropolitan police in february um aft
into an alleged cash for honors scandal
after the prince of wales and a close
friend of his were reported to their
mets
and again at the time clarence house
defended the prince saying that he had
no knowledge of this alleged scandal
sadio in the newsroom thank you
also making the news this morning police
and lincolnshire have arrested a 22 year
old man on suspicion of murder following
the fatal stabbing of a nine-year-old
girl
lilia valley teacher was killed on a
street in the center of boston on
thursday
detectives are not looking for anyone
else in connection with the incident
a mother fighting to keep her brain
damaged son alive has pleaded with the
home secretary to intervene in the case
it comes after the united nations issued
an injunction to continue the life
support of twelve-year-old archie
battersby while it considers an
implication from the family
the nhs trust caring for archie is
planning to end his support treatment on
monday
after a high court judge rules that this
would be in his best interest
her mother said his mother says that if
it goes ahead it would be an
extraordinary cruelty
my boy's really not in a good place at
the moment it's just
it's unnecessary the hospital are fully
in control of this situation
you know and i think that
if they do
go ahead to do that after they've all
they've they know that the un are now
involved i don't think it's going to
look very good for this country at all
a 16 year old girl's been injured after
what's believed to have been a drive-by
shooting in manchester
the teenager was taken to hospital in a
stable condition after she was injured
outside a house party on craney
crescents in the most side area on
friday night
raider manchester police said the girl
is not believed to have been the
intended target and her injuries are not
thought to be serious
the us now where residents in kentucky
have started returning home to assess
the damage done by flush floods this
week
at least 25 people including children
were killed in what officials have
described as an ongoing natural disaster
the governor of kentucky said the search
and rescue operations are still ongoing
and warned that it could take weeks to
find all the victims mark stone
reports for 27 years this has been
eunice howard's home
a house she built with her late husband
now ripped apart
a moment here of community support that
is replicated across this valley and
beyond
within
10 to 12 minutes
i hear the noise and i raised the window
and i seen the water and i knew i had to
get out there
it was in the house and my building
started coming out i said well my house
will be okay
about time my house come out
took about five minutes for that to
happen five to six minutes and it was
gone
from the time i got out of the house
eunice's granddaughter wanted to show us
the power of the water it's moved like 2
300 metres because the house didn't used
to be where it now sits so these are the
foundations yeah
my god
from above it's clear the foundations
below and several hundred meters
downstream what's left of the howard
family home
it is one of so many destroyed by rains
and floods that everyone here says they
have never seen before
the state governor has been absorbing it
all from the air this is remote kentucky
hard to reach hard to help so many who
have lost everything
the number no not to have made it
continues to rise
and devastating stories
four children from the same family
pulled from their parents arms as they
sought safety on the roof of a home
which collapsed underneath them
down the valley beyond eunice's house
people salvaging what they can
they will all need to start all over
again
but this is still a rescue operation
as a major disaster federal funding has
been provided and personnel too
this is still an emergency situation we
are in search and and rescue mode
again that that count is going to
continue to go up and we don't lose this
many people in in flooding this is a
real tough one
it is a sentiment you hear over and over
now with so much extreme weather this
isn't normal mark stone sky news in
hazard kentucky
and mark has the latest for us from
kentucky
well as you saw in my report there it is
the volume of water which is really
quite extraordinary and i think this
image here gives a quite a clear sense
of of just how much there was this is
one of so many gorges so many creeks
around this very rural part of kentucky
and you can see now the water levels
have come down a lot but at one point
they were right up here many meters
above what they should be and they took
with them everything in their path and
as we've driven around here some areas
completely untouched but then in all the
low-lying areas in these gorges
everything has been taken away so
localized damage but where it is damaged
it is utterly destroyed and i think it's
clear from what the the governor has
been saying and what we've seen on the
ground talking to the the local rescue
crews they've got an awful lot to do
rescuing people still people that are
still stranded but a recovery operation
that will take many many weeks
mark stone there with the latest from
kentucky
well here has been a crunch weekend in
the race for number 10 the first ballot
papers are expected to be delivered this
week
with conservative party members deciding
between former chancellor rishi sunuk
and the foreign secretary liz trusts
both candidates have revealed their
latest policy plans now miss truss's
campaign meanwhile has been worried by
the endorsements of more party
heavyweights
sky's political correspondence rob
powell has the latest from westminster
brandon lewis is the latest senior
backer for liz trust of course the
defense secretary ben wallace backed
miss truss on friday
and then yesterday we had tom tugan hat
who was running himself for the top job
but in doing so the former northern
ireland secretary has taken a swipe at
rishi sunak he said that the former
chancellor put up resistance to a piece
of legislation that liz trust was
pushing through around northern ireland
and brexit and said that rishi sunak was
more concerned with pleasing the eu now
the rishi sunac campaign has said that's
not true and that he supported the bill
the whole way through it's not the only
argument though nadine doris the culture
secretary has written a pretty
extraordinary piece in the sunday papers
as well um accusing rishi sunak of being
disingenuous about
his past and his upbringing of being an
assassin of boris johnson and of lacking
empathy now mp's supporting rishi sunak
have called on liz trust to disown the
piece and have said nadine doris is
being disturbing and divisive in what
she's saying in terms of where the
campaign's at liz trust is out today
talking
about education uh rishi sunak will be
talking about rejuvenating high street
he's also got an eye-catching pledge in
the sunday telegraph though where he
says he'd look at potentially charging
people if they miss appointments on the
nhs to help clear some of the covert
backlogs i think looking at where they
both stand it does look like liz trust
is widening her lead over rishi sunak
but what the tsunak camp say is that
he's focusing on talking to actual tory
members he's been on a whistle-stop tour
of some safe conservative seats this
weekend trying to hoover up votes in
those areas where there are real really
rich pickings
for votes
with ballots though dropping on tory
doorsteps from tomorrow and voting
taking place
in the coming weeks or so he doesn't
have that much time to try and change
minds and to try and catch up on where
liz trust is in this contest
welcome back to wembley where later on
the lionesses have a date with destiny
well not really destiny just germany in
the euro 2022 final what kind of final
can we expect well we're thinking it
might be a very very tight one two very
mean defenses who've conceded just one
goal each so far but let's get more on
what we can expect later on today and
how england can get round germany let's
talk to carrie dunn she's a freelance
sports writer she's been writing
about the euros for all sorts of people
and uh carrie welcome along to the show
it's it's the romantic final isn't it
it's the final that really we all wanted
to see and even the germans said it's
the final that they wanted to play
before the whole thing even started do
we think it's going to live up to
expectation
i really hope so i don't see why it
wouldn't i mean both england and germany
have had a fantastic tournament
obviously having a big occasion at
wembley as well add some extra spice i
think it's going to be a great day
do you think serena wiegmann she has
been very consistent so far in her
planning all of the girls said we know
exactly what's expected of us we know
what our roles are
do you think she's going to make any
tweaks or changes to the team for this
one
i don't think so i think she'll be going
with the same starting lineup that she's
stuck with throughout unless there are
any enforced changes obviously and i
just say everyone knows what their job
is everyone has gone in fully prepared
and everyone will have a game plan the
subs will be there ready to come and do
their job when required and yeah i think
they'll be set up very well
yeah but alessia russo must be thinking
what do i have to do to start a match i
mean she her time will come she's so
very young but i mean what an incredible
impact player england have to bring on
after i don't know ellen white's done
all the hard work if you like
yeah um i know what you mean but then
think back to 2015 fran kirby was in the
alessia russo role she was being used as
impact sub so i should say alessia
russo's time will come and yeah what a
fantastic weapon to have there on the
bench if needed
yeah their strength and depth is really
fantastic this time isn't it and let's
talk about uh the two girls who are
vying for the golden boot so on
england's side you've got beth mead
who's on six goals and for germany
you've got alexandra pop um let's
compare and contrast those two first of
all beth mead she has been prolific and
when you're on a roll like that do you
think your confidence is so high it
doesn't matter it's the final she's just
going to continue the way she's done so
far
absolutely and obviously she started so
well with the hat trick and she's she's
obviously not a central striker she's
playing out wide and so
that it's not necessarily her primary
job to score the goals all the time but
yeah her confidence is high she knows
where the goal is and i think that
should be a really interesting kind of
subplot this afternoon her and alexandra
popped together on the same pitch going
for that golden boom
how do they stop pop because um in the
air she has been incredible four of her
goals coming from headers i mean she is
lethal at leaping
how do you stop that or is it actually
quite good that you know what's coming
well i guess there's that you know what
to expect from her to an extent but that
i suspect that'll be milly bright's job
this afternoon millie bryce also had a
great tournament so that'll be one of
our toughest tasks yet i think
yeah can you just highlight how good
millie bright's been because in talking
about alessia russo and talking about
beth mead's goals and sometimes
everybody else gets a little bit
overlooked but minnie bright's been one
of the players of this tournament hasn't
she
she's been colossal and yeah playing
center half isn't necessarily the most
glamorous thing i suppose it's the goal
scorers to get the headlines but she's
been absolutely immense completely solid
calm composed mastering that defense
backline along with leah williamson
who's obviously it captain in the side
for the first time in a major tournament
and yeah that's one of the reasons that
the defense has been so stingy this
tournament
well the feeling comes from the top
doesn't it serena biegman's brought and
we understand a lot of joy
to the girls in this team uh playing
football and concentrating on the
football and remind him that's why they
play football it's because they love it
not because they they want to keep fit
or win lots of money so she has set the
tone but you know do you get the feeling
that these girls come into this final
not thinking oh wouldn't it be lovely if
we could win they come into it thinking
we are going to win there's no imposter
syndrome going on here with this team
they are full of confidence
they are they're absolutely full of
confidence and i thought leah
williamson's press conference yesterday
was fascinating on that i mean they
coming fully prepared they know that
they're ready to take on in one of the
best teams in the world in germany and
on such an auspicious occasion i mean
playing at wembley in front of her in
front of pac stands isn't something that
the lionesses get to do very often
because you know it
it's so rare they get to travel around
the country of of course and see fans
but playing at wembley have packed out
wembley is going to be a very new
experience so it's going to be
incredible they come in knowing that
they have proved themselves as one of
the best teams in the world and now they
get to play another one of the team on
their level for that first major piece
of silverware
now in other news russia today
celebrates navy day with vladimir putin
attending a naval parade in st
petersburg where he's expected to
deliver a speech but i'm now joined by
our correspondent dianna magnay who's in
st petersburg for us and diana do we
have a sense of what he's likely to say
i imagine that in terms of what russia
still insists on calling the special
military operation what president putin
will say is that it is all going
according to plan uh to reassure the
public that everything is fine and to
congratulate the navies and all
the uh russian fleets are represented
here on the work that they are doing and
i think in the background you can just
about make out the presidential boat
which will take him from the peter and
paul fortress past um various warships
missile ships landing ships
up to senate square here in saint
petersburg where he will deliver this
speech but interestingly this morning
we have some news from sevastopol in
crimea which is the headquarters of the
black sea fleet the russians are saying
that a
a low-cost homemade drone sent by
ukraine um has hit the headquarters of
the black sea fleet not much damage but
five people injured they say and
therefore all celebrations in sevastopol
have been cancelled for the day but the
celebrations will continue here um
[Music]
it's a chance for us to look at what
role the navy has played in
russia's activities against ukraine and
actually however much president putin
will put a gloss on it they have
suffered significant losses especially
when you consider that ukraine doesn't
really have a navy to speak of we had in
april the uh downing of
the black sea's flagship
warship the moskva which russia says was
because of um ammunition inside the ship
detonating and a fire causing it to
collapse the ukrainians say they
targeted it with a missile which i think
is the generally accepted um truth uh
you also had another ship that's been
taken down and various um
smaller patrol boats but what the black
sea has been very effective in doing of
course is in blockading ukraine
economically all of the ukrainian ports
all of the grain that despite that deal
stuck in struck in istanbul a little
over a week ago is still in those
ukrainian ports and still has not been
able to move because
i think the question of actually whether
russia has acted in good faith in
relation to this deal is still on
everybody's minds so they haven't got a
single ship out of those ports yet
and of course russia
has leverage it wants to make sure that
it continues an economic stranglehold on
ukraine so that it can't uh uh
you know act against russia in the way
that it wants to so it's not really on
russia's um
it's not really an incentive for russia
to make this deal work because right now
that blockade works for them
diana thank you very much i stand in
there in saint petersburg
well let's stay with the war in ukraine
now in efforts to release grain from the
country's ports well i'm now joined by
professor chris elliott who chairs the
institute for global food security at
queen's university belfast and um as we
were just hearing there from diana putin
expected to speak later today at navy
day do you have any sense at all of what
he's likely to say
perhaps maybe touch on the grain issue
yes good morning vanessa i mean it's a
hugely important day a couple of days in
terms of of trying to get all of that
cereal stored in the black sea ports
released
it's reported there's 15 16 ships
already full of weight ready to go and
and hopefully the first consignment will
leave today but of course there's been
so many twists over the last 10 days in
terms of the signing of the agreement
then
the the bombing of odessa nobody's
really quite sure what the overall
strategy of the russians is
yeah let's talk about those twists and
turns because of course talks are moving
in the right direction but we've we have
been here before russia launching that
attack on odessa as you just touched on
which obviously then changed the game so
what does this then mean for the latest
effort in practice particularly when it
comes to the safety aspect
yeah i mean we have to think about the
safety of all of those sailors on those
ships um
the ships have to navigate through uh
very heavily mined waters they have to
pass the uh
the russian navy which is you know which
is guns trained on up at the moment it
it's hugely tense situation and again
there's virtually no trust between the
two sides this this deal has been
brokered by turkey and the united
nations and everybody's trying to work
towards actually getting some of this
green release which is so badly needed
in many parts of the world
and also then the attack um has no doubt
throwing moscow's commitment into
question as we were just saying raising
concerns and about the safety of those
shipping crews as we're just discussing
and indeed navigating those waters will
be difficult because it has been strewn
with explosive mines
yes they they the black sea ports have
been mined by the ukrainians themselves
and the reason for that was to stop
invasion from from from the russian navy
itself now we we expect that the
ukrainians have very good maps of where
those mines are but still you can
imagine imagine the tension on the
ship's captain who have to navigate
their way through these very very
dangerous waters
do you think that um this has come too
little too late of course ukraine's
president vladimir zelinsky is saying
that the first ship has been loaded but
is it come too little too late for those
countries who rely heavily on grain from
ukraine
oh i mean absolutely not
the united nations have estimated there
is 50 million people more now go to bed
hungry every night because of the war in
ukraine but that 20 million plus tons of
cereal is so badly needed if it's not
released that 50 million could go to 500
million that that's the scale of the
disaster we're facing right at the
moment
and also um the latest development is
coming of course russia then away from
the grain inviting the un to and also
the red cross to probe the deaths of
dozens of ukrainian prisoners killed on
the um in the dunya's prison um the
attack that took place there what do you
make of that how is russia trying to
position itself by inviting the un and
the red cross to carry out this for
probe
yes i mean it's another
escalation in in the war between russia
and ukraine this horrendous incident the
prisoners of war being being killed by a
missile and as always you know where
does the truth lie who fired the
missiles and so forth i mean the the
interesting point is both ukrainians and
russians have have asked you know for
independent verification of what's going
on so
i mean we we can we can only sit back
and just hope that all of these tensions
that are going on in the war will not
impact the release of this so badly
needed food for for many parts of the
world
professor chris elliott he chairs the
institute for global food security at
queen's university of belfast grateful
for your time thank you thank you
now for a check on the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
weather conditions will be mixed over
the next few days but this will become
very warm in the south with potential
for some tropical nights however later
in the week high pressure will return
bringing dry settled conditions which
will stick around for some time this
morning it's mild muggy and dull across
much of england and wells without breaks
of rain in scotland and western parts of
ireland will be largely dry with sunny
skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well across the country people have had
their own way of sharing support for
their lionesses and that included this
household
[Music]
well this was the scene at yesterday's
changing of the guard where the band of
the grenadier guards and the band of the
cold stream guards played a melody of
football tunes in the squad's honor
outside buckingham palace including
neil diamond's song sweet caroline
there we go
you're watching sky news breakfast
coming up we'll take a look at the front
pages with broadcaster and writer edward
dew and pr consultant paul charles
[Music]
climate change is with us and it's
becoming critical but the fight pack is
on
coal is under fire whereas wind power is
booming
you can now have burgers made out of
these rather than those and no need for
fuel just rely on the vital spark
i'm tom heap and i'm joining sky news
for special weekend editions of the
climate show where we'll meet the people
hit by the crisis and also those
delivering crafty solutions
in the end the question is can we reach
a world that isn't based on
burning stuff
find out on the climate show on sky news
welcome back well with us this morning
to review the papers at broadcaster and
writer edward adu and the pr consultant
paul charles well i hear you both though
it's great to have both of you here with
us this morning there's a lot thank you
guys
actually um good morning to you both and
let me just um start off with you um and
go through to the telegraph there paul
there's a lot in the papers about rishi
sunak and this one's very interesting so
the headline there's sunak resisted
efforts to override the protocol what's
that all about
yes don't think this story is going to
go away we've got another five weeks of
this before of course the election on
the 5th of september comes to an end and
we find out who the new leader of the
conservative party and new prime
minister is going to be but all of the
papers and including the telegraph
really do start laying into both
candidates and looking in more detail at
what is making them tick and this is one
that i picked out actually from the
telegraph this morning it's commentary
by lord forsyth michael forsyth you may
remember who was the former scottish
secretary and this is another blue on
blue attack they simply won't stop he
says writing in the telegraph that i'm
not sure the former chancellor gets it
that conservatives believe in sound
money and lower simpler taxes it's his
rishi sunax lack of empathy foresight
and vision that worries me and this
won't go down well in the sunnah camp
because this is another major political
conservative
former leader uh former cabinet minister
who is saying that actually he's not up
to the job and so i think that this is
why i was saying earlier on our earlier
pay-per-view that actually rishi sunat
is going to have to rework his campaign
he needs a reset and he's going to have
to show why he's going to be cutting
taxes and not raising them which of
course was his policy with boris johnson
when he was chancellor um edward i'll
just get your take on this very quickly
before we move on to the next story
rishi tsunak does he need a research and
actually is it too late for any kind of
research
i mean from speaking to loads of friends
and they it's i think the issue is about
about connecting with people and about
being relatable the whole issue
connecting
about his finances and and and how he
approaches things that's i think the
main concerns about people going forward
if it becomes pm is he able to to to ray
and to connect and
we're going to discuss this in a minute
with the next story which is about an
issue an issue in his constituency and i
think it boils down to the issue of
knowing what
how what people are going through how
they able to how he if he becomes pm if
he's going to be able to help people
because i think
fundamentally that's that's crucial and
if
that can't be done or there's not a
significant plan in place in order to
address that then that could be a
problem
okay absolutely we will come back to um
the politics a little bit but let's just
interject very slightly with another
story there's really dominating um the
headlines and i will stick with you um
the edward this is um wagath christie so
the story of the moment really i mean
it's just been absolutely phenomenal to
see the amount of money that's also gone
into this
three million and paul mentioned earlier
when we discussed it in the previous um
uh review
in terms of the proceeds it has to be
distributed distributed to to charities
because i think a lot of people think
well okay yep three four million pound
bill but you know vardy rooney uh let's
face it
they have the money
in vardy's case she has the money to
cover it and remember she may have to
kind of restructure or um
look at her her finances in order to
cover this but it's the whole issue is
of this could happen to to anybody and
it has you know i've had issues with um
with friends who have sent not so much
malicious but i suppose you would call
it banter and then on what's up you say
look
they're not your friends
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna discuss it
next time in the morning i'm friends
with everybody because you know what
they may end up taking me to court and
i've got no money
i'm not in the same case they're the
same predicament as vadi but on a
serious note it's it's it's about um
it's about respect uh supposed to common
value societal values where if you are
friends with somebody and if they send
you stuff you're not necessarily going
to um forward it on to the press or
whatever so
i think it's down to this whole issue of
we we're living in in in a time where uh
everyone is more in
what is more so nosy intrusive they want
to find out what's happening um in in in
their lives and i mean clearly for
this case to to get to where it is um i
i think there may be not just the vadi
and colleen case there may be others
which may come to light and people say
well look we didn't want to talk about
this or to address it but we we've had
to because it's infringed on our privacy
and and on our lives and if that happens
that's sad i mean if that if that's the
case then where where where are we in in
society in terms of privacy and and
respect and i'm not i don't want to come
across as some kind of you know
sunday biblical pastor kind of saying we
all need to live in a in a in an orderly
society but that has to be questioned
absolutely and paul we're not looking
for a friend in this next story we're
just looking for the next prime minister
the next leader of the party we spoke
about um rishi sunuk briefly um earlier
but let's just talk about liz trust
because her campaign seems to be getting
a bit of a boost isn't it
yes and i think you can relate all of
these stories together this morning in
how well people are conducting
themselves look at the lionesses with
the euro final today they're conducting
themselves really well you're not seeing
the equivalent of the wags on the male
side fighting
poor to poor and the same in politics
those that are coming out as friendlier
those that are coming out as not
interrupting or mansplaining like liz
trusts uh are doing much better and the
sunday times is saying that there's
going to be more momentum added to liz
trusser's campaign in the next few days
with both nadine sahawi the chancellor
and brandon lewis the northern ireland
secretary apparently joining her cause
that makes more than 10 cabinet
ministers backing liz truss who herself
of course is the longest serving member
of the cabinet over various governments
so certainly the wind is in her favor at
the moment but as we know the opinion
polls are pretty close among tory
members right now and i don't think you
can rule out rishi sumac at the moment
and um let's just talk about a story
that i find very interesting here um
edward i'll come to you this is a story
in the mail which says the british
workers are worst in europe for getting
back to the office what a scandalous
thing to say is that true what's going
on
you know we were talking about the
friends thing i can actually say that
some friends would be prepared to to
work from home than getting back to the
office i think
covid or the working from home or
lockdown has made some people um
somewhat lazy and they would prefer
working from home or meeting a friend at
their local cafe and and
they may even consider going to the
office twice a week and um i know paul
is not one of those paul even though
he's in a his office behind him looks
rather exuberant and it looks great i'm
sure he does step out um at least three
or four times a week and he does get to
the office or he has his own office i do
the same thing i the working from home
practice i couldn't do it not that i
mean you see my bus collection behind me
it's great but if i if if you if you
said to me ed you've got to stay at home
and work for home forever i i would
trade my bus collection and get to the
office
and what about you then paul would you
trade that beautiful pottery behind you
very lucky to be on holiday at the
moment here it's not my place but
it would be a great office there's no
doubt i'm rethinking where my office
should be
not in london but down here but yeah i
think you know most people have
rethought their lives they want to be in
the office two or three days a week and
have that mix if if they're working in a
job that enables them to do that what is
clear is that the message sent out by
jacob rees-mogg a few months ago about
getting civil servants back to work has
not really worked so still a long way to
go on that we have to get him on the
case there really
it's been great speaking to you both